i want to talk about some very important
missing risk factors for heart attacks
okay
now typically when you
look at risk factors for heart attack
you know they're going to talk about
high blood pressure smoking alcohol
family history age gender because men
are more at risk than females
diabetes cholesterol and obesity right
well
today i'm going to talk about the other
factors which i think are way more
important as far as a risk factor
like what is a risk factor well it's a
certain variable
it's something that contributes to
something it's something that you use to
predict if something's going to happen
or not and to figure out these risk
factors they do various studies
unfortunately a lot of the studies are
questionnaire studies they're
observational studies which are not at
the top of
reliable
scientific studies
unfortunately nowadays science has
really become
corrupted in fact it's become very very
political i think that's probably why
they call it political science
but uh the question is who is funding
the science who's getting benefited
indirectly and then unfortunately if
you're opposing the
the consensus of what science has found
out you're either silenced
censored or you're not going to get
funding for another
study or you might be labeled as
a denier of something and i do want to
touch on the difference between
cause and correlation
because there is a big difference okay
when something causes something like it
would be like a causes b but when
something is correlated
a might occur at the same time as b but
that does not mean it caused b
it's a statistical relationship it's
some association and unfortunately every
day on the news or the internet you'll
see things like
oh high fat diet causes diabetes or
heart disease or cancer they're implying
causation and then you read the study
and it absolutely positively has nothing
to do with the causation there might be
an association but then if you read
further you're going to find that the
person wasn't just on a high-fat diet
there were other variables like they
were also on a high carbohydrate diet at
the same time and because the ketogenic
diet is a high fat diet people assume
that the high fat diet was a ketogenic
diet when it's not
and so there's just a lot of
manipulation when you see these studies
nowadays like here's here's an example
of correlation like inactivity causes
weight gain
well
it doesn't cause weight gain i mean it's
associated but it's not causation before
i get into some actually really
interesting information i want to just
first
define a couple things related to this
cholesterol thing right here right
many people that go on a ketogenic diet
they end up having higher amounts of
cholesterol and then they get worried
they get upset they're freaking out
what's going on i want to really explain
that
when you go on keto you switch from
burning glucose to burning fat okay
you're burning a lot of fat and the fat
cells are releasing and burning
triglycerides and cholesterol is also in
the fat cell and that's going to be
released and so you're having a lot of
oxidation of fat going through your
bodies
and so the question is is it dangerous
is it pathogenic well today we're going
to talk a little more about this
cholesterol because just because you
have higher amounts of cholesterol does
not mean there's a pathogenic situation
going on at all and by the way as a side
note
when they talk about obesity being a
risk factor there's something called an
obesity paradox which is
wild because
it is true that there is an increased
risk of developing heart attacks if you
have obesity but having weight gain
can actually
be protective
in those people who already had
heart failure very interesting i should
do a video on that but just because
someone is overweight doesn't mean
that's a risk factor personally i think
it's more of the visceral fat okay not
necessarily weight all over but i don't
want to get sidetracked but this is what
i want to explain right here
you have these things called
lipoproteins like the ldl hdl
basically what those are they're little
transportation shuttles
cargo units that are transporting fat
through the blood because most the blood
is water-soluble so we have to be able
to push this fat through and so your
body has these little containers or
buses that it transports the fat and the
protein shuttles and inside you have the
fat okay so that's what they really are
and so when you have
hdl that's high density lipoprotein
and ldl is low density lipoprotein now
what do they mean this density thing
well they're really talking about the
relationship between
how dense something is with protein
versus fat okay because remember we have
this protein
shell and then we have fat inside
so the high density lipoprotein would be
a lot more protein less fat
versus the low density protein which
would be less protein higher amounts of
fat so the hdl is considered the good
cholesterol and ldl is considered the
so-called bad cholesterol but
there's some more information you need
to know there's there's two types of ldl
if you look at ldl from another angle
there's these little particle sizes and
so you have one type of the ldl called
the small dense okay the particle size
is small dense and that is the type that
is
pathogenic it creates problems it can
invade the arteries and start creating
problems but when you have the large
buoyant
particle size
okay
they don't invade the inside of the
arteries okay they float around
but they're not creating problems for
you so this is why
if you don't get an advanced lipid
profile test you're not going to get
this data you're just going to look at
the total ldl and that might scare you
but i highly recommend you get
the advanced lipid profile test
now there's something else i want to
bring up and i'm going to keep this very
very simple because it gets complex if
you have apo a1 and apo
b now what are these so all you need to
know is this one right here apo ai
is a part of the protein in the hdl okay
remember this is a protein in fat
and then the apob
is the protein in the ldl and
understanding this relationship between
these two like the ratio of these two is
a way better indicator
than even knowing your ldl or even your
hdl okay
this one which is connected to hdl is
protective
okay this one is atherogenic and so the
ratio of this you want higher amount of
this lower amount of this is a really
good predictor of heart attacks okay but
they don't really mention it on here
they just focus on cholesterol right so
we really want to understand
is that ldl particle size small dense
or more large buoyant okay
that's what we want to know and we also
want to know the ratios between these
two it is helpful to understand
triglycerides many times people have a
high triglyceride when they do a lot of
carbohydrates not when they eat a lot of
fat because this has turned into energy
in the body okay
but this is not the best indicator
for heart attacks
this one is right here okay this might
be a new term for you
again i'm going to try to keep this
really really simple
lp and then small a okay that's as far
as i'm going to go as far as the depth
of what this is but
basically this is a really good
indicator
of heart attacks okay
it's kind of like a variation of this
ldl
and involves
more oxidative
ldl the oxidation coming from carbs that
can invade the arteries and create
inflammation
and clots okay and what this really does
is it competes with
the enzymes that you have that keep
blood clots dissolved
so if we have too much of this
we increase our risk of
clots in the body
this ratio here is a really good risk
factor and the small dense
ldl is a really good risk factor total
ldl cholesterol now not a good
indication to tell you what's going on
in the heart especially if you're on the
ketogenic diet all right so now let's go
into
these additional missing risk factors
the number one best
risk factor okay i would even go so far
to say that it's probably the causation
of heart problems okay it's not even
correlated but that's just my own
opinion and i'll tell you why in a
second high insulin called
hyperinsulinemia
you can also do a test to see how much
insulin resistance you have which is
also correlated with high insulin too
it's called the homa ir test it's a
really good test to measure insulin
resistance and while you're testing that
you're also checking the high insulin
too now as far as high insulin goes why
is that so significant
as a risk factor
well because
it explains
most all other risk factors you see when
you look at all this random data the
more you can align the data
to one cause
and everything makes sense then chances
are that's the most likely cause okay
and in this case let's pretend it is
high insulin as the main causation okay
let's take a look at all of the other
data does it make sense does high
insulin cause high blood pressure the
answer is yes does it cause high
cholesterol yes does it cause diabetes
yes
if you're getting a high amount of sugar
that's stimulating insulin over a period
of time you're gonna develop insulin
resistance you're gonna lose insulin
function
and you're gonna get diabetes so a lot
of diabetics initially have high insulin
okay
does high insulin cause obesity of
course it does does high insulin cause
high ldl the small dense particle size
the answer is yes
does high insulin cause another variable
which i'm going to put on the list which
is sleep apnea or sleeping problems in
general the answer is yes and does high
insulin explain the visceral fat it sure
does and does high insulin explain
another variable i'm going to talk about
which is inflammation the answer is yes
and does high insulin explain
a high cac score which is a coronary
artery calcification score and the
answer is a big fat yes because the
calcium is coming in there from all the
damage that's done from the high levels
of
insulin and insulin resistance
so let's go through the missing risk
factors that relate to heart attacks
number one
high insulin
and a test for insulin resistance called
homa ir okay number two a cac score
coronary artery calcification score that
basically correlates to how much calcium
is in your arteries and that's one of
the best predictors not just of heart
attacks but of
any reason for dying okay the more
calcium you have in your arteries
the worst shape you are in all right
number three your april b to april a
ratio you want high
apo a and you want low apo
b
this gives you a very high statistical
correlation
and it's predictive of a heart attack
okay number four ldl small dense
particles this will also give you a good
prediction
and then we have number five lp small a
this is a very powerful risk factor as
well and you should get a test done to
see if yours is high or low and number
six your sleep right if your sleep is
poor
it will increase your risk of getting a
heart attack in fact if your sleep is
less than five hours a night your risk
factor for heart attacks goes way
way up
and then we have number seven stress
stress is a huge factor because we have
this constant release of cortisol
cortisol tends to act like insulin
mobilizing
proteins and fats and turning those into
sugar which is then going to increase
insulin so
number seven is really a part of number
one and then we have eight visceral fat
that is the fat in you around your
organs
that gives off inflammation and
inflammation causes more insulin
resistance and if you have visceral fat
that also means you have liver fat so
really it's not the
superficial subcutaneous fat that's
around your body that's pathogenic it's
the visceral fat that's my own viewpoint
and then we have number nine
inflammation okay the more inflammation
you have
the more
insulin resistance you're gonna have the
more insulin you're gonna have the more
pathogenic especially in your arteries
and where does that come from does it
come from the saturated fat
no it doesn't it comes from the
unsaturated fat the absolute worst food
that you can eat for the heart okay
besides sugar
and refined carbohydrates is the deep
fried foods because when you cook
these unsaturated
fats okay like soy oil corn oil
canola cottonseed oil and even sunflower
and safflower oil what you're doing is
you're generating a tremendous amount of
inflammation in the body and you're
contributing to heart disease right if
you were to consume saturated fats or
even deep fry in saturated fats like
lard talo coconut oil
you would not have near the problem with
inflammation because these unsaturated
fats are very unstable and they're very
inflammatory what's really bizarre to me
is what they're recommending to prevent
a heart attack or what you should eat to
prevent heart attack right
grains
polyunsaturated fats okay this is what
they're recommending
if you have a heart problems
beans legumes fruits
and even they allow a good amount of
added sugar don't ask me why
but like i said before science is
becoming more political and you're going
to have to do your own research to find
the truth now if you have not seen my
video on the coronary artery
calcification score that would be a
really good one to watch next i put it
right here check it out